[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is father
greg boyle who was one of my favorite
chats conversations
time spent togethers that i've ever had
on this podcast he is absolutely
incredible he is the founder of homeboy
industries which is uh now my current
obsession uh i read tattoos on the heart
i listened to him on other podcasts i
listened to his talks on youtube and now
here we are having this conversation i'm
so excited to share with you i would be
remiss remiss if i didn't say right here
up top please donate if we all donated
to homeboy industries that would be a
huge
wave of donations i'm gonna do a benefit
for them i'm gonna donate uh to them as
well do recurring donations to them i'm
such a believer you're gonna hear all
about it in this episode
but if you would like to if your heart
is moved go to homeboy industries.org
and set up uh even a small recurring or
one-time donation
just for the pleasure of it it it you'll
feel good knowing that you're supporting
something so
so beautiful and truly truly
one-of-a-kind and wonderful
here are some less beautiful plugs like
my stand-up show although one of these
largos we're gonna do for uh homeboy
industries i'm just trying to coordinate
it with father greg but the next one is
september 8th if you'd like to see me do
stand-up and you're in the los angeles
area go to largo dashla.com
we are stacking those shows andrew
santino did the last one
uh river butcher dimitri martin um i'm
forgetting a lot of people but we always
have incredible incredible people
schumer
schumer stopped by
mullany has done it nick kroll it's just
always always always the highlight of my
month so even if you're not seeing this
in uh around september 8th 2022
we do it every month we're there every
single month so just go to largo
largodashla.com
and look for pete holmes living at largo
we're also brought to you by some pete's
picks i'm wearing one now
can you get this
can you see that okay
these are perfect jeans i didn't put
these on because we were recording the
intro katie and i i i put these on
because i put these on every morning
perfect jeans are my favorite pants
they're the most perfectly named pants
because the perfect jean is the perfect
jean i hate hard pants but i don't like
pants that look like they're soft if
that makes sense i want soft pants that
look like they're jeans that pretty much
are jeans they just have two percent
spandex and 2.5 rayon for extra comfort
and movement that frankly uh it says it
right here i'm gonna say it your man
parts required
it's in the copy
i couldn't pull it off wearing like a
yoga pant or like a linen pant that's
just not me i'm not sting i'm not phil
collins but i wear jeans every single
day and to have some mobility basically
these are comfortable enough to sleep in
i have slept in them they are the best
pants that i've ever owned not just
because they're stretchy and comfortable
but because they're durable you know
this area always tears i'm pointing for
the audio people i'm pointing to the
crotch area always tears on my jeans
because i over wear them not with the
perfect jean they're so well constructed
maximum durability constructed utilizing
the highest quality materials and sewing
techniques
i haven't had to replace a single pair
so i have them in blue dark blue i have
in gray i have them in black they look
fantastic val loves them they last
they stretch and they're comfy what else
what else do you need to know oh how
about this the perfect jean for the
imperfectly perfect men are just 60
bucks when you use code weirdo
at checkout so liberate your lower limbs
with the one and only perfect gene
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
honking eggplant the perfect jean has
you covered take a peek at
gene dot www.theperfectgene.net
that's the perfect j e a n dot nyc no
not genetics
jeans
and use code weirdo for 25 off at
checkout and of course show your support
of the show second and lastly this is
the last ad then we'll get to father g
this is my apollo neuro it's a wearable
piece of technology that helps my body
manage stress this is the pete's pick
that i've turned more people on to
in real life i'm shooting a tv show this
week
two three maybe even four cast members
from the show are have already used this
promo code to buy an apollo neuro
because i'm just constantly talking
about what a difference it's made in my
life it uses almost sub-perceptual
vibrations that help you relax sleep
focus and be more productive it's like a
wearable hug for the nervous system
using touch therapy to help you feel
safe and in control it's worn on the
wrist or the ankle a polyneuro delivers
gentle soothing vibrations that
literally train your nervous system to
recover and rebalance after stress
there's energy
energy and wake up which you can really
feel is wonderful before or even during
a workout social and open is what i have
it on right now because we're about to
record an episode it'll be running the
entire episode just telling my nervous
system it's okay keeping me alert
keeping me open clear and focused is
wonderful if you have add symptoms if
you need to dial in and focus on your
work i use it constantly rebuild and
recover
i always joke is what i put it on after
i speak to my parents it just helps your
body kind of come back to itself it and
this is the point in whenever i'm
talking about i tell people it's not woo
this isn't a crystal this isn't like
sinking up to the stars or something it
is made by a friend of mine we became
friends after i started using it he is a
board-certified neuroscientist and
psychiatrist they have been studying the
impacts of chronic stress in humans for
nearly 15 years the more you use it the
better it works
it's not a mood ring apollo's effects on
stress sleep cognitive performance and
recovery have been proven in multiple
clinical trials and real world studies
and there are more on the way i really
love it
sincerely wear it constantly i literally
charge it when i'm in the shower because
that's the only time i'm not wearing it
and pretty much not using it so you can
get 10 off and show your support of the
show by going to apolloneuro.com
weird that's
a-p-o-l-l-o-n-e-u-r-o dot com slash
weird for ten percent off and feel
better with just something you wear val
wears hair is on their ankle so if you
if you don't wanna i like i'm an
enneagram four so i like people being
like what's that i'm like let me tell
you uh anyway
enjoy
father greg boyle
check out tattoos on the heart check out
his other books and if you don't want to
buy something just go on youtube and get
ready to cry it's literally become my
routine is watching one of his talks in
the morning listening to his book on the
way to work
weeping in the car
and then i just remember to be tender
and loving
all day it makes a huge huge difference
in helping me remember to be the person
i want to be in this world so i hope you
enjoy this chat i know we did
get
into it okay well we just lost a little
bit of a recording but i can remember
what we were saying one i'm so thrilled
you're here i could say that faster sure
i said it a little bit more sweetly
before right that's okay but i was
saying that it's these episodes that i
that i cherish and i get the most
excited about so i just want you to feel
welcome that's really just no i do thank
you but i want them to know that i made
you feel welcome to be honest as well
and i was saying that i was just at the
montreal comedy fest and
it was so much
comedy
i'm just gonna repeat it there's that
simpsons episode where homer goes to
hell and they say you like donuts how
about all the donuts in the world
it's funny watching you have to
re-listen to me say this
it's very showbiz you're doing very well
and that's a little bit it was like do
you like comedy how about all the comedy
in the world
and then i said
i think it's a it says something about
how my brain works whatever's in front
of me becomes my reality
and that's that's good and bad it can be
bad because if all that's in front of me
is my ego and my persona and my value is
earned by getting laughs i can get a
little depraved
depraved not in a bad way i just mean
like my tank gets empty
and i would go on walks and listen to
richard rohr and stuff but it wasn't
enough i needed like a full
day off to just reconnect so i've been
really looking forward
and i listened to you and i watched you
and i felt
uh
like i was coming home like i was coming
back to myself
as opposed to the the peat that i sell
yeah and that i'll bring to a location
for a fee
i started to remember the present moment
i started to remember
my identity in god i guess we could say
my center
not i'm only as good as my last show so
i'm coming to you in a very
and you just got in and i just got in i
got in last night at about midnight and
i'm really excited to see you so this is
doubly exciting one
not to put the onus on you but like i
need
just as brothers a reconnect yeah just
just sitting with you is helping
um
and i i also was curious
how you do with that how how do you
keep the line open you know to your
we could say soul or or just to your
center or to your
you know what it is is like i forget i'm
beloved
when i get lost in the game of like
well are you on the poster did you get
the deal
did you get the standing ovation like
you start to forget that you were born
accepted
and i wonder how do you remember
as you've done such a great job telling
other people that they are
beloved children how do you remember
that
well you know you know in recovery they
talk about one one day at a time but i
think that's way too long you know
i think it's like a minute it's like
then you kind of get to every breath
because we're we're we're addicted to
once and for allness you know like okay
i've vowed to do this or i want to be
loving
or i've decided to have my practice
but you know it's like you think it's
once and for all yeah you know and it's
just which is very it's addict thinking
by the way yeah and i'm an addict and i
tend to be very black and white yeah i'm
either in or i'm out yeah but then if
you kind of connect it to every breath
you know cherish with every breath
and then you but it's hard to do that's
your practice so it's like you you
meditate in the morning or something or
you have your space and your time you go
well now i'm good to go
is that what you do well that's what i
do but you're not good to go you know
because an hour into
your day
you know you want to throttle somebody
and so
that's just kind of
but that's why i think it's important
the practice has to be connected to
every breath
you cherish with every breath is what i
kind of cherish with every breath yeah
you know as you're saying it
katie was struggling to turn that off
and i'm like
no you did great
i know
there is no judgment there but i'm like
again what's in front of me is what's
happening so katie's trying to figure
that out and i'm like and you're telling
me this beautiful thing
it's okay right i know
but i if there's anything the podcast is
about is it's about being honest being
like yeah i hear you and i'm like it's
it's the one button mark power
the on off button it's like how quickly
but even in my language how quickly we
can lose it when we're talking about a
connection to the divine
is there something to
owning and accepting and loving
our frustration or our anger or
everything being welcome even in
ourselves the forgiveness we have for
reality we extend to ourselves yeah i
mean i think you do that and you and you
kind of that's the aerial view but but
you have to kind of bring yourself back
to the present moment and how you do
that is connect with your own you know
breath
just you know
now hear this as kind of a mantra i have
now hear this now hear this now here
this look kind of like you would have on
in those old movies on uh now here
there's yes eisenhower his troops from
ecuador like kind of steam some kind of
warship or something oh yeah but it's
kind of now here this as in periods
after each thing now hear this and i
will say that as somebody is coming into
my office
and i'm preoccupied or i'm worried or
how am i going to get
to this next thing and i have to see
this guy first and
so i kind of do a little now hear this
now hear this which keeps you
here
with this person
listening as intently as you can
cherishing with every breath and and
choosing to do that
it's hard but i think that's what the
practice is we think the practice is
limited to whatever you is you do you
know like in the morning i pray i sit
but if the practice isn't a 24 7 now
hear this
then i don't know how you you can yeah
you can't sustain it
yeah and you think that's it that's i'm
good for the day
right you know i ticked the box yeah but
it doesn't work it i mean it works for
you know five minutes after you've been
sitting yeah
i actually find that to be very true i
can have
moments of
pick your pick your human thing extreme
lust or anger or greed or just pettiness
10 minutes after i had a sit or a walk
in the woods i mean like give me the
best of the best to walk in the woods
and then 10 minutes later i might just
be like
i can't stand that person's face
just like immediately but you're saying
go eat go gentle on yourself and and we
all need
it right now yeah even though we just
talked about it maybe i need it right
now well because you're always trying to
return
to yourself and to your anchor and your
center as you said earlier yeah and uh
so how do you return
you know kind of and you're saying the
breath i think that's kind of what i do
when i that's your intentionality
you know because the homies will always
say to each other at homeboy industries
you know like when the homies who kind
of run the place now
and somebody fights and fights happen
you know
and then they'll call the person in i
said well he said this to me you know
no
you allowed him to take you to that
place
so so the idea of being taken to that
place whatever that means you know and
we all kind of have a sense of it
you know
you you have to kind of stay absolutely
anchored
in the core of your being otherwise
you're going to get taken to that place
by how annoying that person is or how
frustrating he is and this is the ninth
time you've asked him to
to cut that [__] out you know and then
all of a sudden
you've been taken to that place
so i don't know how else what what's the
remedy
to that human thing it doesn't mean that
it's bad
necessarily to be taken to that place
but you don't want to lose your
your center
yeah
i i say this on the pot all the time but
it's it's not
like when you're doing a task one tenth
of it is the task and nine tenths of
staying connected to your we could say
again the center that's not what the
quote says but yeah i think that's
really interesting but i think that's
self-forgiveness again having been at
this festival
and i am not an enneagram one but i want
everything to go well i want to do my
job well and in fact if i'm being honest
if you'd like a glimpse into my ego i
want to do the best i want to do better
than everybody else on the show yeah
well sure and sometimes if i don't
my friend laura bites was like you you
just talk to your child self and go you
don't have to be perfect all the time
what are you again i'm a well i'm a
three wing four
although richard thinks i'm a seven okay
but so this is the thing because i know
you
tell me well you you know it better than
i do and richard knows it better than
anybody does but
but i think there's a you know people
will say i'm a two
i feel like an eight
but the thing says i'm a seven so
i don't know but i think that's
i i would suspect that everybody says
people say i'm this yes i feel like that
yes but the test says i'm this yeah i
mean is that true well mirabai thinks
i'm a four
i mean
but so for people that don't know what
we're talking about we're talking about
the enneagram
and the seven is the enthusiast and when
richard says you're a seven i'm like i'm
enthusiastic about you like i'm like
like i'm clamoring at his words and
everything so of course i look like a
seven but then i'm like you should see
what i just told you
the three wants to do better and
actually
embarrass their competitors almost like
i'm not proud to say that yeah yeah but
my favorite movie is there will be blood
for [__] sake you know what i mean
it's like
sevens don't love there will be blood
they live homily you know they don't
want to watch a movie about a guy
climbing to his mansion where he dies
alone that's that's the movie of a three
even though he's humiliated in the
process we don't care we're like my
personality still goes like you should
do that get away from everybody
and succeed
let me ask you this about our breath and
staying in it and i heard you speaking
about
delighting
we could go back to the enneagram if you
like but delighting in in the moment and
who's in front of you not being a big
thing how much of that is mental and how
much of that is
stopping thinking
like you know what i mean like
what you said one of the ways you don't
tire at your work is is you just take it
who's in front of you right and give
yourself to them
and don't try to get them but make sure
they can get you
and you kept using the word delight like
find the delight like i'm finding the
delight in you right
how much of that is a mental thing where
you think
okay greg don't forget find the delight
or are you trying to get it into the
cellular level where you just well it's
a decision you have to choose to delight
and then i i think we would both agree
that there's some people you're with you
go wow this person's amazing and a ton
of fun
and maybe
easy to delight in but then there's the
intentionality to ch i'm gonna you know
duty to delight is what um
uh dorothy day used to talk about you
know where she chooses
but it's a duty to delight would you say
it's like i've never heard that dude
it's intentionality i think she got it
from ruskin but it's it's uh you choose
to delight in the person in front of you
it's more like attention you know it
doesn't mean that it's you're dying of
laughter with every person it's not
about laughter
it's about
choosing
deciding
to kind of see kind of see this person
as god does to the best of your ability
so then you're getting underneath your
homies always talk about finding the
thorn underneath
you know which is kind of allows you to
be merciful and to say
you know this violence that guy who just
disrupted the apple cart by fighting in
our lobby
you know what language is the violence
speaking you know because you want to
get underneath it the thorn is the
thing this the thing the wound the pain
the
what's broken right now
i heard you talking about that
and for those that don't know you work
with with gang recovering gang members
or gang members yeah we'll just say gang
members
well i mean it kind of is like although
we've never said recovering gang members
but that's kind of what it is you know
well i've heard you compared to
alcoholics yeah yeah i mean it's it's
about recovery but it's about attachment
repair it's about restoration it's about
discovering the truth of who they are
that they're exactly right and they've
always been right
but they haven't lived from that place
yet you know and
wait until you
taste that yeah
you know that they belong that they
belong and then you do it it's not
something i
i don't transform anybody but
transformation happens there
and you know
uh
and it's a place where people
you know feel cherished
and that's how the world changes when
enough people feel cherished love or
lack of it as yeah fred rogers said is
the
course the root of all problems yeah
that's really interesting tell tell
people a little bit
i know i'm making you repeat yourself
but you know this is show business
not in the bad way
i want to show people what you do
what do we get wrong
about
gang violence just as a way to start and
then we'll go wherever we go yeah well i
mean you know it's about a lethal
absence of hope and so people think it's
bad people doing bad things but like the
middle east i heard you people think
it's like oh these two groups well i
kind of compared
say that it's not like the movie no
that's what i mean yeah where it's where
it's uh conflict right but or northern
ireland or something there's it's not
about anything it's
it's an indication of
of that people aren't able to imagine a
future because they're so in pain and
traumatized the violence is a symptom a
symptom it's an indicator it's the cough
that tells you you're allergic to your
cat you know right forgive me for
quoting you but it's like the alcoholic
saying i would stop if only my lady
would come back if only my wife came
back but you're like actually you need
to be rehabilitated yeah and in your
case
you've already said it you need to be
cherished
yeah so it's not it's not uh
rehabilitation is kind of a word i'm
trying to think words i don't use too
much you know because it's like
it's like
you're returning to what you know
it's right you know i mean healing is
kind of a different thing so the day
will come hopefully
when we stop punishing wound and we seek
to
you know
heal it
and and the largest mental institution
on the planet earth is l.a county jail
so that kind of indicates wow you know
uh howard how we're doing you know what
i i sometimes think about this like what
will the legal system look like in
2177 or something and with the
advancements we're making with
psychology and brain
uh you know chemistry and all these
things meaning this is an extreme
example but i'd love to hear your
response to it
you the the sniper in texas one of the
earliest mass shootings
wrote in his suicide note he's like a
month ago i started feeling differently
and i had all these you know
irrepressible urges
and please examine my brain basically i
donate my brain to science
and they found a tumor in the part of
his brain that controlled those types of
impulses
and then you're like well this is a big
question and feel free to pass but i i'm
sure
uh whatever you have to say will be
fascinating
where is accountability i mean when you
start looking at interconnectedness
you see that nobody's just acting
[Music]
nobody's a a a splinter self they're not
by themselves they're they're products
of their environment and what do we do
with accountability where would jesus be
with accountability with
withholding somebody accountable for
what they did yeah i i don't know why we
as a culture we're kind of uh that's a
big thing accountability and
responsibility and we feel like we can't
hold these
you know two thoughts at the same time
you know that
but the truth is you want to be able to
get at what this was about you know
david brooks wrote recently about the
uvalde
uh killer you know in and saying that
you know he was not it it was not mental
illness because he was never diagnosed
with mental illness i go well so i mean
just we missed it have you met my family
yeah exactly
you know nobody healthy in the history
of the world has ever done such a thing
so i don't know i mean and presumably
people die of cancer and perhaps they
were never diagnosed sure it doesn't
mean they didn't die of cancer right you
know so
you know
like for example i you know uh
you know i don't want to defund the
police but
isn't
everybody longing for the day when
policing is obsolete and our prisons are
empty i think that's a good thing to
long for that so
you know in the same way that jesus
saw the guy having seizures and he says
he's possessed by a demon well no he has
epilepsy so we know something today he
was wrong you know i love jesus but he
was wrong
it was epilepsy here's a pill so i would
like to to think that we're in a
different place now where you have the
aces the adverse childhood experiences
and
and and you go everybody walks through
the doors that homeboy is a nine or a 10
on the aces
i'm a zero
on the aces what is the aces aces at the
adverse childhood experiences so it's a
check off thing of ten things you know
parents were uh addicted my father was
in prison i was sexually abused i was
physically abused i was neglected it's
all these things that children are
exposed to
and if you're four or five experts would
say you you chances are you're going to
have
difficulty socializing and even have
physical
uh health problems
so i'm a zero you know i mean i grew up
not far from where we're talking right
now and wonderful parents and
great siblings and
privileged
and
educated etc and won all the kind of the
lotteries that people win
and some people don't so i'm a zero on
the aces but every homie and home girl
is a nine or a ten wow which is
extraordinary
but that sounds like a diagnosis you're
like look this is what's happening well
it's an it kind of opens a door so it's
not you know morality has never kept us
moral it's kept us from each other and
so
so this isn't about morality so then you
have to let go a little bit
of accountability
and responsibility a little bit
you know people need to be stopped need
people need to be held accountable
and
explaining doesn't excuse stuff it just
helps you
you know prevent it from happening again
i think
you know where you can kind of say well
what's this about what's it mean what's
it pointing to what could we have done
you know what if what if his mom didn't
put cigarettes out on him or hold his
head in the toilet and flush till he
nearly drowned
what if we could have intervened
all that stuff i think is helpful it
doesn't let people off the hook i mean
right this is where you get the cliche
you know the system failed them right i
mean it's it's not just they did it but
it's like the whole
world community i mean again you know
what would we have done
what would we have caught
you know like with the evol i don't know
very much about him the uvalde
shooter but you can go back to all of
them you know the the fourth of july
shooting in highland park uh
illinois all of them they all have the
same kind of
you know what would you have done how
would you how would we have paid
attention
to this person who was clearly in pain
nobody nobody healthy does this
right i've heard you say that it's like
if you give a gang member a reason to
get up tomorrow they won't be wandering
the streets
you know i'm oversimplifying but looking
for someone to shoot
walking on in the wrong neighborhood
looking for trouble i guess we could say
or hoping to die you know we think that
they're hoping to kill but they're
actually hoping to die that's so pete
rollins you know rollins yeah he he had
this very cool idea i thought about a
genie about a genie and there's a genie
and but he only grants unconscious
wishes
so most people that go to this genie
just evaporate because most he's like
most people unconsciously desire
annihilation and i was like isn't that
brilliant i was like
i mean
i'm actually trying to have some
solidarity here like we have
uh
the gang
members and you have me and and
sometimes we feel the same way you know
what i mean like you have this
unconscious desire to vanish because you
get overwhelmed or you get afraid or you
feel unsupported or whatever it might be
and also people carry more than
than others and it's it's not fair i
mean i've never had to carry what i just
came from a funeral of a young woman who
was killed
and uh
this morning this morning
and she used to work at homeboy a long
time ago
she was like 27.
and
and i've never had to carry what she had
to carry you know in terms of parents
and
and degree of difficulty and trying to
navigate her life and
so i don't know i mean i i
rather than
you know the morality of it and kind of
wag your finger at it you you i mean the
homies have taught me that from day one
you know
tell me well they've taught me about you
know um
how do you stand in awe what people have
to carry rather than in judgment and so
you see the kinds of things that they've
had to navigate in their lives
huge huge difficulties in
unspeakable things have been done to
them yeah and again this doesn't excuse
violence but
sensible people want to explain it at
least get at it and kind of go whoa
how can we help
you know like the bodhisattva kind of
notion how not just to relieve suffering
but how could we be helpful here you
know as a society
yeah i was gonna say isn't there
something i i see us both
doing our best to be like look there's a
place for accountability and justice and
there's times when people need to
be you know removed from a situation
let's just stop i always say stop i like
stopped thank you
you can see me
trying my best not to say the wrong
thing but i like stopped
but i i often think like
god's love doesn't please our mind
either does that make sense sometimes i
think god's
liberal
the way that i see god as as the yes
or the the piece of paper everything is
written on
we don't even like
all the things god loves you know or or
that god allows reality we don't like
reality
and like we don't agree with god you
know i mean in terms of
so i read a bishop the other day again
talking about uvalde and he was trying
to be sympathetic to the community that
suffered so much and he says
as scripture tells us
god stands with the victims and not the
victimizers and i and i put it down it
was in a newspaper and i went
huh
maybe he could well prove that i guess
that that's what scripture says
but
it's not the god i believe in yeah you
know and so like
our mutual friend nearby starts talks
about it you know
once you know the god of love you fire
all the other gods
and so so i go yeah no i don't believe
in that god for a second even if he
could prove that scripture says that's
true
i mean uh you know
you and i can have compassion for the
person who did this
and in what universe is god
less compassionate than we are you're
stealing a thought right from my
uh probably 15 16 when i was starting to
deconstruct i didn't know i had yeah but
i was like
if i in my i couldn't even talk about it
publicly but in my own
love
thought experiments if i could find
compassion
what how am i lapping god yeah exactly
laughing i just lapped god
yeah that's a great image
[Laughter]
because that's that's exactly the
problem because all of a sudden
your god is too puny
well talk a little bit about that if you
would you
again i'm going to keep quoting you but
you said
i said something similar i wrote an
episode of the simpsons i was quoting
richard
but it was i that my character gave a
sermon on the simpsons and i was like
we've we've made a god like us
we made god in our image instead of the
other way around we're supposed to be
and i was like when you look at all the
different types of flowers really i'm
just saying the rain falls on the just
and the unjust the same thing yeah when
you see this like
grotesquely liberal
love it doesn't like i'm going back to
the we don't want rain to fall on the
thorns but there it is yeah would you
talk about like we made a god in our
image because we want to be worshipped
so we think god wants to be worshipped
that's how we project you know
um you know and annie lamont always says
you know you've created god in your own
image when god hates the same people you
do you know
and so but that's the same same notion
that richard always talks about
yes yes we're creating god's image and
our image of god creates us
and so that's
i think we're doomed in a way that if
your god is puny you can't be otherwise
but if your god is spacious
and and expansive
then that gives you room
to be that way as
um
you know as inclusively as you can be
so i mean i i attribute for in my own
growth
the homies have taught me this because
you know
you had people saying these are just
pure evil
and uh and i don't believe in evil i
believe in horrible
and terrible but i don't use the word
evil because it creates the very
distance that god wants us to bridge
and so i don't believe it and i just
think if if we say evil it just means
we're not even trying
you know and and i just don't
so i stopped doing it even sin you know
like the mystics kind of go
love god and do what you will yeah i
mean julian of norwich it specifically
talks about uh sin is kind of
oh god i don't it doesn't have any
substance that's how she said it and i
agree with that you know once once you
know trauma
once you're trauma informed
what are we talking about sin
it's not very helpful it it worked and
that's the thing he worked i mean and
then it's true in our culture
the truth was i remember a guy got up in
san francisco and he was a gang
conference and
and i spoke at it and he spoke at and he
was pounding on the podium about some
program and he said listen people this
works
and i remember in my program i wrote
yeah but i bet it doesn't help
but later on i read that i go what was
that about i go not everything that
works helps but everything that helps
works
but
but our upbringing
you know i think
you know we were kind of sold all that
stuff because it worked and did it work
my ass was in church every sunday
because i thought it would go to hell
yes it worked
but did it help not by a long shot not
even close yeah and so homeboy
industries has sort of taught me that
if you do the thing that helps it works
that's kind of a byproduct
but not everything that works helps
and so the the decision is do the thing
that helps it's it's about invitation
like i think we're being invited to
stuff
and and it's joy my joy yours your joy
complete it's not about cut that [__]
out right it's about hey come over here
you're gonna this is where the joy is
does that make sense yeah oh yeah no
we're sitting at the same table and i
love it
i i liken it to the everybody poops
thing it's like it's very easy
to sell something
when you're can you remember i remember
being a kid and even thinking the fact
that i went to the bathroom was kind of
questionable you know what i mean being
like am i okay i have poop coming out of
my plate three times like not clean yeah
not broken i knew i was okay but i was
like
i'm a beast i'm some sort of beast and
then forget it when i hit puberty and
now i'm blind like i can't even you know
how your brain can't recall pain i think
it also like it can't actually recreate
pain in your mind uh it's a preservation
technique i also think you can't
remember how horny you were when you
were 12. right like you think you do
yeah but you don't you don't because it
was so awkward and you didn't know what
to make of it yeah you it like women
delete childbirth you're just like
forget it men delete how horny they were
when they were 12. so when you throw
that in the mix but i'm just saying like
if you want to hook somebody there's a
movie called selling god it wasn't a
perfect movie but it was a good movie a
documentary and it was like it's very
basic marketing
um create a need okay you're born sinful
then create urgency you're gonna die
and
you either go we're back to that binary
and out good bad heaven health thing and
then of course that's going to work and
what i'm hearing you say and and tell me
if you agree
it's a richard roer point but he goes in
our
in our country we think if it works it's
true
so for example i was just talking to
somebody about marvel movies and i like
marvel movies i'm not this isn't shots
fired against marvel movies but take any
environmentalist nobody's going like
what is the environmental footprint of
making a marvel movie and i've been on
the set of movies
you might blow up a car 28 times but it
doesn't matter because it makes a
hundred billion dollars yeah or there's
probably way worse things trucks
millions of trucks
carbon emission all that stuff but no
one in their right mind would go against
something that's huge and profitable
because it works so it must be true yeah
but what you're saying is
just because scaring people into god
works
puts butts in seats right as richard
would say it also keeps the clergy
employed right because we need you to
clean us yeah
every week yeah
unless it unless you can kind of
you know like i think it was the gospel
on sunday where it's uh
you know
the rich guy who kind of builds the
tower to hold all his grain and
everything and then they go what a fool
you know because tonight you're gonna
die yeah and now
what good is it yeah and so so jesus
sells that parable but the last line so
many that are like they're like chris
rock jokes yeah they really are yeah
that's kind of that's fierce it is but
the last line is about uh
you know growing rich in the things that
matter to god so you know so i'm
preaching on that i don't care about all
that this isn't about bank accounts
this is about growing rich so if you
kind of distill the thing it says cut
that [__] out don't be greedy don't you
know stop that
but the last line is about
growing rich in the things that matter
well that's the thing i'm gonna that's
the invitation so fine my insight was
find the invitation because it's always
inviting you to joy not to cut that [__]
out you know and and so you want to find
the joy
you know if people people think that
being a christian for example is like
some grim duty
but
but it's really kind of where the joy is
at least for me yeah you know at the
margins with folks who are struggling
you go wow this must be hard i go no it
that's where the joy is that's i feel
i feel kind of selfish
i i i believe you and if there's
anything i can offer you that's unique
for me as i was just at a
smoke-blowing
festival
where you blow smoke up my ass i blow
smoke up your ass and we all walk around
as ram dust would say i say i see your
outfit i see your disguise and i
validate that it's real do you see my
disguise and validate that it's real
yeah we all just go around telling each
other that our our masks are on straight
and you really are pete homes and i go
and you really are that and here's an
award or like and here's a special
headlining gala or whatever it is yeah
and i just want to not you don't seem to
need encouragement but i believe
everybody enjoys it
it doesn't it doesn't work i'm not
saying
i i can it's a paradox on one hand i'm
so grateful that i get to do something
so so rare
and so uniquely lined up with my talents
being comedy but on the in the other
hand i'm going like
i think in the same verse jesus says
don't store your treasure where moth and
rust can corrupt so the real the real
[__]
the real [__] and i get
intoxicated i get seduced
like salt and light flavor and
illumination like these are
sexy things these are alluring things
and when i get them and when you know
them when you hear them i'm saying like
the the
it's not just a duty spirituality it
actually it actually makes me start
inflating again because i was just at a
place where all we were doing was
you know filling up a silo
when we were going to die that night
yeah but it's also your gift you know
and so i i you're not diminishing your
no no no because you understand you know
and then how necessary it is for people
to laugh and to kind of be lost in some
kind of
moment where you just say well that was
a you know a good
use of my time yes but then there's all
the other stuff that well i'm talking
about the badges and the who said what
to me and yeah it's a real orgy of that
it's it's tough it's
tough i
so richard has a line where he goes
life isn't about you you are about life
yeah and i every morning i would say the
festival's not about me i'm about the
festival i'm one of the co-creators of
this
joyful thing that people need and all
that stuff but if i didn't take that
moment
i know the the depression you get we
actually kind of become immune and
someone could go you're the greatest
thing in the world you don't even feel
it yeah so
enough about me
i'd love to hear you talk a little bit
about what
what is the real treasure what is the
pearl of great price and all that and
how do you
identify it and how do you commune with
it yeah i don't know if it's if it's the
same for everybody you know i mean it's
it's how do you
it's
what is same i think is
you know uh to find your true self and
loving and then then you love being
loving so it's not about return it's not
about if anybody loves you back then you
don't even care because that's the kind
of god we have who could give two shits
whether you love them back we don't we
don't believe that because our dna says
i'm a bad boy yeah and it also says that
god says uh
as i have loved you love me back
though you won't find that anywhere
really yeah god says as i have loved you
so must you have a special preferential
care and love for the widow orphan and
the stranger it's so not
what we expect yeah you know it's about
loving folks who are who the world says
we can live without you
and and so then you kind of go wow
that's the kind of god we have that's
the kind of love i want to be
and then you you try it on for size and
you go wow this is
this is the most joy i've ever known
you know so i think it's like that i bet
but but not that everybody does the same
thing
you know
and uh do you see a corollary with
fulfilling your life's purpose
lining up your talents plugging into a
community and sort of waking up to your
connection yeah but you know so
because i listen to you you know so i
know leela and val
and that's your
that's your con connective tissue to
tenderness and on an ongoing intimate
way yes
and
you are in possession of your gift
you know which
there's nothing
that's holy
to kind of say well i'm going to use my
gift sometimes it means it here
sometimes it means on the road sometimes
it's a filmed thing whatever it is
sometimes it's this yeah you know and
and you go yeah i
i'm i'm good at this i i it's okay to
find the thing you're good at i mean
that's not like counter
well that's something i do anything i've
brought up to dave david nichtern who's
a great buddhist teacher and
my friend and i i was saying
i find it very strange or i used to
that i would do stand up
but think of what think of what i'm
saying i'm connecting with 300 people
and really becoming like one thing and
then after that
i really feel vanished like you'd think
i'd be the most pete holmes i've ever
been but afterwards i actually feel
what do you mean by vanish anchored in
in uh my true self i guess you could say
in in the oneness of things
meaning i get like a spiritual
it's cheap to call it a kick but i feel
calm i feel centered i feel loved and i
feel loving
the joke val and i make about leela is
if she ever wants something she just has
to ask me after i get off stage you know
what i mean it's because i i don't
that's that's the most open-hearted
place so
to go back to what we were saying when i
be went into comedy
my church
my mom's friend who had the gift of
prophecy uh they said
wrote me a letter about the the
dangers of going into something so evil
and
what a strange journey it's been to come
to this other say and i go
that's the unlikely place god was
actually hiding
and richard would say that's the only
way god gets us to do anything is he he
dangles what you want and sort of
sabotages you or or surprises you
does that make sense oh yeah i think
absolutely yeah
and and then i think people don't really
find something
find
the thing that they're good at you know
there's nothing wrong with that
otherwise it's you're a slave to
you know somebody else's expectations or
something i wonder how many of the
homies
i have to think they're funny
homies oh my god funny gang members
because can i say that one of the
points of comedy you'd be shocked
especially when i'm working it out and
trying to find out what i'm gonna do
yeah how much it's just funny to remind
people that they're gonna die there's
this real like
there's there's something really funny
about that silo bit yeah the guy that
puts all his grain away and then he died
that night that's a joke yeah and i
wouldn't be surprised if people laughed
this podcast i've called the prodigal
son jesus's closer like he would that's
that's the big
finish yeah and that's a that's a good
opener this time we have we all have
openers we all have closers we all have
the
the as whole we called it you have to
pepper your talk with self-defecating
humor
and then so you do but it's actually
true you have to kind of uh
be self
um
you know kind of disparaging lower
yourself a little bit a little bit so
that people can go oh okay well he
doesn't take himself too seriously yeah
you know i mean it was kind of a good
advice you know mm-hmm so you lit up
when i said there are funny homies i i
just wonder how many of them would be
great comedians oh my god they're just
amazing it's one of the it's one of the
counter things when people say this must
be hard bearing kids you know and which
and that is
but life isn't hard there you know it's
it's hilarious people
you know
we're in a group in my office in in a
bunch of navigators and a woman she goes
well today's my 10th anniversary
of my marriage and i said wow and i know
them both you know and both gang members
and
and somebody had recently had a kind of
a a
minor stroke where they one of the
homies older guy had some paralysis in
his hands so we were talking about that
and and her man had a stroke a couple
years ago and she was saying i remember
when he had a stroke i mean
and uh
and i asked him in the hospital when it
came to
do you remember who i am
and he goes yes he knocks and says yes
and i said [__]
the whole room died we fell out of our
chairs
and it was kind of a testament to
how much they get on each other's nerves
yes but they were also quite um
it was very kind of telling about how
and how everybody just enjoyed it they
just kind of
i'm hilarious i mean you should come by
sometime i would love to and and in no
time you will see how
um
smart witty quick fast
it's you know the reason i'm not
surprised is it's people who are in
touch with reality or with the absurd
when i say absurd i don't mean bad but
the cosmic joke the sort of like the
fragility all of that stuff
breeds
comedy
like people who
need to make themselves feel better that
need that hit that endorphin
and need to see who's with them like
they're these little sonar pings of like
who thinks like me
is there anything funnier than just
calling out like
what a scary situation that was you know
exactly am i the only one that just i
was [__] my pants
and you need it yeah that's what i'm
doing my whole
life is going but you know so like we
have two words all the time we have
probably six groups all the time and
and i heard a homegirl giving a tour
and uh
overheard her because i never give tours
but the homies give the tours
and at one point she chose to say
here at home boy
we laugh from the stomach
and i went wow that's exactly right
as opposed to some kind of superficial
thing laughing from the stomach that's
it yeah that's the whole that's the law
and the prophets right there that is it
you know to be able to do that because
everybody knew exactly and now we say it
a lot
you know
um
when you comment on
the quality of the laughter it was
everybody was laughing from the stomach
which is not a thing i'd ever heard
before yeah but as soon as i heard it i
went that's exactly right yeah the deep
from your deepest
most whole
most holy
place that's how our people are laughing
do you have to
[Music]
this is i'm just embarrassed that i i'm
just so unfamiliar with your world that
i'm worried about embarrassing myself
and asking a dumb question but
when i'm with comedians that are from
the projects or whatever
there's a language of
like the jokes take on a different level
it's like can i hang
do you ever feel that you're being
tested if you can hang i have to imagine
yes in lots of different ways well but
seeing
i've been doing this for almost 40 years
so i kind of
i got the jargon and i understand you
know but do you ever make fun of like do
you ever do snaps and stuff like yeah no
yeah i think we all do it and it's like
uh
you can kind of get into that mode you
know
a comedian i know is felipe esparza i
don't know if you know oh no i'm
embarrassed yeah yeah he won the
what's that comedian show the last comic
standing yeah he won that and okay and
gave
half the money to homeboy and no way
yeah he was homie from the projects and
he's had specials
that's uh
nat not gross yeah gave half away
because the taxes are have to yeah yeah
so but he grew up in the projects was
it was that homeboy he
publicly talks about his own recovery
and addiction and stuff and i sent him
to rehab
and uh
but he'll do
you know comedy
in the early days stuff about growing up
in the projects which
you know
hilarious for
all of us you know folks who are kind of
familiar with it you know
but you go ahead and keep yeah no but so
then you know so i don't know i i get it
and but do you make fun of
yourself would you call yourself corny
or
make fun of yourself for being a white
guy or whatever it might be
it's funny it's it's kind of
it's not a thing you know i i don't
think it's uh
which i think it people disqualify
themselves all the time they think
you know how could i possibly
be a beneficial presence at homeboy
industries right as a volunteer for
example yeah
because i'm white and i come from
privilege or whatever but it's
but that's the kind of great liberation
is knowing that if you're the proud
owner of a pulse you know and if you
and if you you know can you love people
can you
be reached by people can you receive
people can you cherish people well then
you don't have to be
their color you don't have to be a gang
member of their color yeah and i think
that's the great liberation because they
feel like only ganglers can connect the
gang members
yeah i mean that's that is what i'm
talking about i don't want to be
embarrassed but that is what i was
thinking you know and i think
it's okay i bet a lot of people think
that but it happened in the old days you
know when i in the early days when i was
doing shuttle diplomacy in the projects
and and you were trying to kind of get
rival gangs to talk to each other before
i realized that that
supplied oxygen to gangs and was
probably not a good thing but we would
meet with
gang members who were
kind of you know hardcore gang
intervention workers you know they were
trying to
and there was always that moment that
came you know and i'm a white priest
among all these african-american latino
you know gang outreach workers
and then they would say you know
i think the homies are going to listen
to us
more than they're going to listen to you
and i'd always say the same thing i go
well if the task is talking to gang
members you're right
but if the task is listening to them
who can't do this
you know if the task is receiving them
or allowing your heart to be altered by
them who can't do that well let me let's
talk a little bit about that because
val
i doubt
there's a chance you heard me say this
but
i sometimes struggle even just watching
a movie
where people are foolish or uneducated
like really like it's hard for me
this it might be scapegoating but i
really feel like i was conditioned
to go well that's ridiculous
and uncomfortable
and if i even sympathize with it i'm
somehow aligning with this weakness
and the reason i'm asking like the joke
is well give an example of that i'll
give you an example boogie nights i
never i love paul thomas anderson but i
really struggle with watching boogie
nights
uh because i can't stand watching a kid
get into porn start doing cocaine
uh you know go to a guy's house with
guns and almost die yeah i'm sitting
there
again
i will not be made a fool of so this man
is a fool and i disown him and like i
can't even enjoy the movie and val was
like you just have to watch it
from a neutral place like from a
spacious place and just this is this is
okay this is what's happening but you
watch it from a place that says how
could you be so stupid that's what i'm
doing and you watch it from a place that
maybe says something about you know
morally
um
oh yeah out of whack and i don't want to
admit that i am like it's another core
negative belief is that i'm stupid or
that i am weak or as my mother would say
carnal that i would do cocaine or that i
would be in pornography but of course
there's of course a part of me that
would love to do cocaine and be in
pornography but i can't even
get over that hump so my question is
i finally learned how to watch boogie
nights and now i i like it quite a bit
more can appreciate it i can appreciate
it but when you're dealing with real
people
i guess it's a silly question but like
how
how do we open our hearts
more how do we turn off the judgment
like i feel my father's voice
you know who's a loser and who's not a
loser like and guilt by association all
these things
that the temptation
that when you're talking to a homie and
they walk away and you go like yikes or
whatever it is you know what i'm saying
like
how do you how do you is it just by a
road that's a good question i think but
i think it's also again part of your
practice is to cultivate
what saint ignatius who
founded the jesuits
whose feast day was yesterday
when uh and and he used to talk about
he has a word in spanish called
acatamiento and it means affection at
all and it's kind of how what it's a
stance in the world
so the opposite of that is judgment and
and you want to get as far away from
judgment as you can just writing down
affection at all
at all and so i always talk about aw but
then i i ran across this word that he
used
in the last 12 years of his life and he
kept using it in his spiritual journal
and then he went back and he circled it
and the word was a catamiento and it
comes from the word akatar which means
to look at something with attention
which is kind of what we want to do in
our lives we want to look at people
in situations with attention not
judgment
and and so it's kind of how he part of
it is how he felt towards god affection
at all
but then he he didn't settle for this
mystical
singular thing between him and god
he wanted it to be a stance in the world
here's how i will see people so then you
watch boogie nights and you go
pain yeah wound
brokenness yeah but then you kind of do
that you know
how do you look at the insurrectionists
on january 6 and you go well nobody
healthy did that
i'm sorry it has nothing to do with
politics it has none of us are well to
all of us are well and we both love rom
dots and it's like
you know walking each other home means
you're you're you're loving people into
wholeness
so i don't have to judge them
you know nobody chooses to be unwell
you know it chooses them and we're all
on a continuum
of
you know
being not well
and how do we help each other
just in this moment
to be healthier
you know and it's not a once and for all
health
it's a breath by breath it's a breath by
breath and it's also
healthy is holy and holy is healthy
there's i don't think anybody's ever met
a
holy person who wasn't healthy
you know i don't think and holy not
meaning moral i just want to point out
it doesn't mean it also doesn't mean
perfect yeah but it means whole it means
it means whole and and so like in the
family of things not again not to get
political but you know it's like people
will say well joe biden is a
who i know
it is a good
decent
um
man
and you might somebody else might say
but donald trump not so much
but i think those
we name things incorrectly it's about i
think joe biden is is a relatively
healthy well
whole person and i don't think donald
trump is i don't have to hate him i
don't think he's a bad man you can have
this look i have to look you can have
the same affection at all
affectionate at all and and
your starting points are
all of us are unshakably good and we
belong to each other now you can roll up
your sleeves how do we help each other
how do we walk each other home
how do we
you know help each other be whole
and and uh
and and that was a campaign ad that was
on uh
buses for the la county mental health
department and it said none of us are
well until all of us are well and i
remember seeing that on a bus i went
that's what i believe
because then it's it's not about
how could you be so stupid
or
these are bad people
no
you know it's like if they're indicators
of this is healthy or not so healthy
i think this is why we love when sarah
silverman or somebody goes to the house
of hardcore trumpers and you see
can we can we separate someone from a
group and talk to a person yeah we love
stories like green book is a movie about
somebody with complicated racial
feelings with a black man and we love
those we can't get enough of those i
often joke we don't have enough time for
everybody to go on a cross-country
road trip with a trans person or a black
person or a gang member but or a trump
supporter or a trump supporter i mean
yes
then i i would love to have yeah well i
should watch what i wish for but like a
bonding
moment a human moment with these people
but you know matthew dowd who who
is i really like and wrote a good book
whose title escapes me but
he was saying you know he was talking
about why did it take a hundred years
for reconstruction
and he said
because a third of the american people
do not believe that all men and women
are created equal and then he said why
does it take 60 years from emmett till
to donald trump
and he said because a third of the
american people
don't believe that all men and women are
created equal i think he's right
but now what do you say a third of the
american people are stupid
or bad or evil
no i go well that's an indicator that
that or
none of us are well until all of us are
well it's about wellness healing yeah
and it's about people need to
but if they don't need to kind of figure
it out
you know like oh now i see
nobody healthy
yes doesn't believe that all men and
women are created equal so it's about
health not so when you see a man
attacks an aged asian woman on the
streets of san francisco you go oh asian
hate crime well i you know it's not
about hate it's about health nobody
healthy has ever done such a thing yeah
and and so what when you say hate
i denounce hate
well then it's about me it's
self-congratulatory and this is why we
don't make progress because we don't
name things
correctly
it's about it's about health it's not
about hate and then you can stand with
affection at all
at the guy who did that because
he's in pain that he didn't choose yeah
yeah and the same for our our families
and our friends and everybody around us
yeah you said something that was similar
to what mother teresa said you said
people are like we're gonna face hate
head-on so they'll have a hate
summit
and you're like it would be better if it
was called a health summit yeah and
mother i'm sure you know this quote
she's like i won't go to an anti-war
rally let me know when you have a peace
reality you know she thought those types
that type of language was important yeah
aligning with
what you want instead of against what
you think it creates a high moral
distance you know and it's also from
them yeah you go exactly it's it's
self-congratulatory i think
as someone who's done it i can tell you
it isn't
well affectionate awe
not to get too heady but a little heady
it seems to me that when i can and i can
do it right now
look
from
affection at awe
is another way to say that it's like
looking from a state of being almost
like putting
more contemplative looking
meaning looking without thinking
looking at something without
labeling it how many exercises are there
where it's like look at a tree but drop
the label tree
and let it change you instead of you
imposing your will on it let it into you
richard tells great stories you don't
have to go to jerusalem to meet christ
or anywhere
anything this couch
seen
well seen perfectly seen honestly
would be enough to convert you if you
could
quiet your mind enough so when you're
looking with affectionate so what are we
doing we're softening we're being loving
we're being spacious that's affection
val has so much space for me that's a
good way that i think of her love and i
try to give her space and then awe is
appreciation but it's also a tension
but it's looking from
now we're getting heady but being itself
it's it's i'm looking from the
phenomenon of awareness
not almost not even as peed pete looks
at you i go well he's older you know i
can go he he might be bald he has a
beard he has glasses he's got a shirt
with his bra all that you know and now
i'm not even seeing you anymore right
is it about how we see is it i think
it's a lens exactly yeah it's a lens and
you find your lens you know your
mystical lens is what i would call it
yeah you know and then it's and it's a
it's a mystical filter
like i have a spiritual uh director
sergio who's a homie and we email every
morning and he always talks about the
mystical filter so
we're sending we're commenting to to
each other like on the readings of the
day
and you'll read jeremiah and you go
yeah i don't believe in that god
that wants to you know shower
horrible things on us because we're
wicked i don't believe in that god and
he talks about
you know
a time for the mystical filter so he'll
read it through the filter and go oh no
this is just human beings
it's scripture but it's human beings you
know projecting onto god
their own anxiety and why wouldn't they
have why would why would human beings
stop doing what we've always done yeah
just for the period where we were
writing the bible that's right but they
don't always do it sometimes you go oh
they were there the god is tender which
is why jesus quotes certain parts from
the old testament and not the stuff and
i'm going to presume it's because he
didn't buy it i think so too yeah
because he had a mythical lens
that he would put on and you'd go nah
once you know the god of love
you fire isn't that the whole picking
grain on sabbath thing i mean like
exactly jesus was
fierce
he was this is one of my things that
richard really taught me was that like
i don't know it's funny it's what we're
drinking our liquid death water i was
gonna joke with you i was like isn't it
funny how much death imagery jesus uses
how
the the baptism is like a drowning i've
said this a million times but it's it's
not
gentle it's i'm gonna drown you
it is gentle too
but you he's talking about you have to
die you have to die you have to die you
have to you have to be willing to let it
all go
again i'm reminded of your homies the
ones on the street there's like a
certain urgency you know jesus says god
is burglar god is
wait for god like you're waiting for a
thief in the night there's a certain
urgency
that only comes when you're
waiting to die right that's in the dow
de ching as well it's like careful as a
man crossing a frozen lake
you know that's
it when your hand is
actually moving where you're conscious
that's a lens that's a lens you're
looking that's right right and if that's
what your practice what you work at
that's why it's it's you you you think
you put the glasses on and you have the
lenses
but you don't you know it's really a
constant
and you you know pema children always
talks about catch yourself
you have to catch yourself
because you're starting to
you know move up it's not like sin but
you're starting to move away from
affection at all yeah to
to the judgment that creates a distance
you know
that keeps it about me
as opposed to delighting in you
you know
and that
which which is why i don't have a lot of
patience for
for burnout stuff you know people always
say god how do you burn out how do you
not burn out or
but i i always tell my staff
because i learned this the hard way
because there was a time when it was all
about me
and it was i was trying to save rescue
fix
you know this is kind of obvious but but
then you decide no
you know
and
no amount of me wanting that homie to
have a life will ever be the same as his
wanting to have one so so you have to
kind of wait
for it to happen
but you also it can't be about you if
you're burning out i tell that to
our
senior staff if you're burning out it's
because you've allowed it to become
about you
and it can't be it has to just be
and it can't be about outcomes which is
sort of the idea of the
if it works
you know evidence-based outcomes which
is
the bane of non-profits you know they
all have to prove
that it works and i'm not interested you
know i you know we're not called to be
successful
as mother teresa says we're called to be
faithful so you try to stay faithful
to what you believe in as a technique or
as a strategy or as a way of
a lens
but you don't want to be the one doing
it
right doing what
doing the fixing yeah you're just made
available no
because if you're receiving people if
you're allowing your heart to be altered
if you're being reached by them
you know
you know your
transformation will happen because it's
exquisitely mutual
it's not me
yeah saving you
pardon the interruption weirdos just
another reminder please go to
homeboyindustries.org make a donation
they also have a is it a 5k 5k for
charity for them
coming up if you like to run and help i
just like to send money and help and sit
on my couch but some people like to run
and help uh i also bought some homeboy
industries a t-shirt and a hat it's a
great way to support
um obviously as we're discussing in this
episode
at the homies as father greg calls them
make this apparel help make it so you're
supporting their jobs and their cause
which is incredible and uh yeah
that's it also we have another pete's
pick here for you
a real favorite of mine which is feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you don't feel namely stress
anxiety pain fields is a premium cbd
that helps keep your head clear and feel
your best it's hassle free delivered
directly to your door and cbd naturally
helps reduce stress anxiety pain
and sleeplessness there's no hangover or
addiction i have been using cbd for many
years and i can attest that feels is
absolutely as good as it gets helps me
unwind helps me with pain helps me fall
asleep you name it i even you sometimes
use it when i'm working because it just
elevates my mood and helps me ease into
what i'm working on which is wonderful
take a few drops of fields under your
tongue and feel the difference within
minutes the thing to remember about cbd
is that finding the right dose is
important and every dose is different
and field even we'll send you a flight
of different strengths of cbd to try
which is how i dialed in my dose so if
you need a dose of chill on the go you
can even try feels new cbd infused mints
for a clear-headed feeling with a bonus
fresh breath in fact feels offers a free
cbd hotline to help guide your personal
experience so that you find your perfect
dose the feels customer service team is
dedicated to making sure you get the
best use of your cbd i love this company
and they're not just shoving cbd down
your throat they want to make sure you
get the exact right one in the exact
right dose good on you feels joining the
fields monthly membership as i did using
this promo code makes your carousel
self-care easy you'll save money on
every order i can attest to that the
discount is substantial and you can
pause or cancel any time so start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels f e a l s
dot com slash weirdo and you'll get
fifty percent off your first order fifty
percent off your first order with free
shipping that's f e a l s dot com slash
weirdo to become a member and become and
get 50 off
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping feels.com
weirdo alright guys enjoy the last half
of our chat with father greg
yeah this is something that i i struggle
with when i get exhausted it's because i
feel like i've read enough and i've
listened enough and i've been quiet
enough or whatever and then i feel like
my tank is full and then i'm not proud
of this i'll go out and i'll hose it out
but like then it depletes
and i've run out of what i thought was
compassion but it was actually just an
ego trip it was just me going like i
know the quote for that i know the
passage for that i read a book about
that and look at how calm i'm being as i
say it to you it's really show business
i mean it really is like a persona
when what i hear you saying it's more
like a jellyfish or something there's
something but you find the thing that's
eternally replenishing which is
delighting in you
yeah delighting in
in lila and
val delighting in the people you
encounter
and choosing to do that then it's
eternally replenishing but if it's about
you rescuing people or saving the day or
being successful
then you'll be depleted but i don't
think there's anything wrong with
exhaustion i mean that just means you're
spending
and that's fine yeah but if it's
depleting depleting is different than um
i think
then
then um
you know
then exhaustion you know depletion means
your battery you've connected it it's
actually losing power yeah
what do you do if you're
if i was just not your cup of tea
you know like this is easy we have very
similar beliefs and and i think we're
enjoying each other this is easy yeah so
i'm having no problem to have affection
at all
um what do you do with difficult people
yeah no but if i kept interrupting like
i just did interrupting or swearing or
saying blasphemous things or or you know
or that i think you're stupid you're a
fool homeboy industries is a waste of
time what do you do with this yeah you
know that's a good question
i mean i i think uh
have you ever been like you know i know
dangerous people
i know where you live
i was really hoping you would laugh at
that map quest
so there we go but you know
yeah it's hard i i i don't wanna you
guys like this is easy it's not easy you
know because it's obviously it's
it's easy to delight in people who are
delightful yeah but then
um how do you kind of
you know
shift gears a little bit with somebody
who's being
absolutely
and it happens only every day at home
boy
belligerent hard-headed yeah you have to
make this little jump rather than saying
you know what an [__]
you kind of go oh
i mean it's hard to do
you know because you go
i'm not enjoying this person but you can
appreciate you start to appreciate
that's what affection at all is and
that's why you practice at it because
it's going to be it'll come in handy and
it'll be difficult
i'll give you an example maybe it'll
make it easier now that you did a lovely
job i'm just saying
one of the things that i think makes
this podcast work is i'm never hesitant
to give you an example from my own life
for the guests please
i was in montreal and my mom
texted me
she had texted me earlier and and she um
she mentioned that someone she knew
had a charity
and that they wanted uh to forward the
information to me
now already i'm on edge yeah like if you
really want to know it's it's not good
what i feel when that comes through
because i'm like
this is about you you want to get your
son
uh your successful son to donate to your
friend's charity so you can feel like
that me none of that
i don't know if you know byron katie i
can stop and go is that true i don't
know if that's true like i'm getting all
worked up about something i don't know
it's true but
you know what can i do i'm i'm still
getting
very worked up yeah
but you know i i calmed myself i i took
what did
pima children's i caught myself because
i'm i'm shaking as i'm replying to the
text i go just don't reply take an hour
and then reply and that's one of the
greatest life hacks of all time yeah and
i just realized yeah send it to me i'll
take a look and i wrote and if i fee and
if i donate
um i have all the information or
something like that but i'm trying to
have a boundary and be like
you don't get to tell me
i don't like this yeah i don't like this
yeah so then a couple weeks later uh
while i'm in montreal she texts me again
and she goes i spoke to my friend and
she said you haven't donated yet and i'm
like full uppercase [__] like [__] off
like you can't do this to me
uppercase
just
i i feel like a petulant child yeah and
it's very hard in that moment
to have affection at all what i tend to
do and i have to think that you would be
in favor of this is i find compassionate
friends i talked to my friend lara bytes
who said your mom can't put something on
your to-do list which i thought was
beautiful
people that validate my feelings people
that say it's safe and right and okay
it's not say right or wrong but it's
okay that i feel how i feel i might even
be wrong
my mom's intentions could be completely
different
but
i'm actually going to try and answer the
question for you it seems like maybe
we need to give ourselves time
and patience before we can have that
affectionate that it's not going to
necessarily be like
well father g said have affection also i
should immediately be fine with this or
what do you what do you think well i
think it's a stance you know it's the
stance of your own intentionality and
choosing so i'm gonna i'm gonna decide
to do this today
knowing
that you're gonna be tested only all the
time
you know by by belligerence and
hard-headedness and people who are in
pain and are flailing you know
i mean that is uh i i don't mean to sell
out my mom but because we share dna i
know in those moments there is a
flailing-ness to it there's a there's a
want for connection yeah and i'll do
anything to do it i would even say she
might even
i can't know but my mom would rather i
be mad than ignore her yeah does that
ring about that's right sure
absolutely yeah she's even told me as
such she's like
she'll she'll poke right where i
don't want her to poke because she'd
rather i lose my temper than then just
be like hi mom i love you mom she
doesn't she doesn't want that and that's
actually one of the things i like about
her she wants something
real yeah she wants the real stuff
but it's hard for humans you know
because
well but because we want to win the
argument and
we want to end up on top
yeah but i think you know the reason we
make progress when we name things
correctly and so when we can identify
stuff i wonder what that is
i wonder why she did that i wonder what
that means
you know it seems so simple talking to
you now i'm like
but in the moment you're valuable i see
you yeah i i
i value you yeah like you say i cherish
you yeah
that it's so simple on this couch yeah
but there i am at lunch and i have a
show to do that night but you're right
it's all identity and when we talk about
boundaries it's like what are those
boundaries protecting it's usually a
sense of me on top in control yeah not
vulnerable winning did you say winning
yeah winning yeah i am a winning thing
and now in comes mom and i'm like i'm a
losing thing this can't be
and then as val tells me all the time
she's like it's not just the feeling
it's that you're ashamed that you can be
made to feel that way so quickly yeah
and how vulnerable you were that's right
right why is she so good yeah but it's
been being taken to that uncomfortable
place
that takes you from your center now you
have to go perform and you're feeling
kind of forget it yeah i've had a
vulnerability hang over all week because
there's so much
they're seeing so much of you yeah
i know that sounds crazy for someone who
wanted to share themselves right but
when you have to do it that much for a
week i flew home and i was just going
over everything i said
and i uncovered that core negative
belief which is
i'm a bad boy like
and then i listen to you for 10 minutes
and i go
i've
you know not to change the subject but
i've had
mystical experiences where i've been
lost in that
undulating fountain of yes and love
where the thought of of pete even
existing as a separate entity was the
funniest joke in the world yeah where i
was just
like and yet i can still be on an
airplane going like
you know i said that to that person did
they was that okay and forget in in
cancel culture it's it's really
interesting in my and i'd love to talk
to you about it that must be hard how
well i i in my experience it's like
culture is caught up to how i was raised
it's like we'll create a hell
for you we'll we'll judge you and we'll
send you to hell right and we'll cut you
off and you're disgusting all those rev
i'll spit you out of my mouth that's
what we we're doing it to ourselves
and i'm like what took you so long i
mean like that was what i was doing when
i was 11. that's right but what what
that that's a great place to go
is
well can i just ask
are you an extrovert or an introvert i
mean because i don't i don't buy just
the fact that you perform that means
you're an extrovert i mean some of the
best actors in the world are introverts
yeah
during the lockdown i think i learned
that i'm an introvert
yeah
i mean i mean i can get up and speak in
front of 10 thousand people and i
you know i it doesn't uh
but put me at a cocktail party
forget it i can't do it it's torture
you'd be a good comedian yeah we just
find each other and talk about how much
we hate it yeah yeah so but i think
that's i don't know where to put that in
the in the mix you know because
in terms of your own depletion you know
and that and yet you get energy on the
stage yeah you know yeah and
uh but then you need
your solitude so much of it yeah
i i went to see ramdas and it was one of
the happiest weeks of my life and i was
alone for most of it i do well in a
hermitage i think yeah i i would like
that yeah
um but at the same time it depends now
that i have al and leela it's a little
bit less true yeah yeah i want to see
them yeah but can i um
can we talk a little bit about
forgiveness and canceled culture just
because i'll i'll give you an example
i went to a party recently and there was
someone who has been canceled i didn't
know they were going to be there
i have to say that isn't that funny i
have to be like this was not my doing it
was literally like yeah um
a surprise yeah and i was in a strange
situation where i was like my
spiritual belief and it's how i acted at
the party i didn't blow them off i
because they were a person and they sat
with them and talked to them and we
actually i actually ended up talking
about falling upward and
and how it's sometimes being broken and
humiliated is
is where god is hiding for us
and i also
saw a little bit from them some of that
wisdom not a not a spiritual person
talking about
what they had learned and what they had
gained from being
sledge hammered whether or not that was
i you know in this case who knows i i
can't that's not my point no i
understand i know the internet wants me
to take a side i'm not even saying who
it is yeah somebody i don't even know
very well but like
you were there i was there and when it
was a person it was easy to talk with
them and it was okay and i felt okay
about it and val felt okay about it but
i would love to hear a little bit
don't let me put words in your mouth but
i i have to think you love people that
have done
things that are extreme more extreme
than what i'm talking about i mean on
whatever you want to say the scale of
crime right but what do we do what do
you make of
what's happening right now
you know it's funny i'm not a big
forgiveness person because i feel like
you know and and i feel embarrassed
because i'm about to have a book come
out that
kind of
it's really a compilation of a lot of
quotes and stuff from my
other books and but it comes from a
thing i did a little talk
thought for the day it was a bumper
sticker and it says forgive
everyone everything and so that's now
the title of this little book give
everyone everything forgive everyone
everything i love it and yet you know i
feel like we we settle
you know forgiveness requires that all
parties are in agreement you know
which is not how god operates you know
so we we settle for forgiveness when we
should hold out for mercy so mercy is
something different from mercy is
is a larger thing than forgiveness
forgiveness waits for an apology mercy
doesn't wait for anybody it doesn't wait
for anything it was already given it's
already it's there it's like
i don't need you
canceled person
to say anything to me that mercy is uh
oh god do you know what i mean it's it's
the green light it's it's just because
then you you love being loving rather
than
measuring stuff out
and then so
but we want to measure we want to we
want to we want to kind of just we want
to cancel we want to cancel we want to
escape and put our evil into that's
right afghanistan or iraq or or into
whatever it may be yeah and then we can
continue to deny that that is in us
yeah
but but forgiveness waits
for somebody to do something
and there's no waiting in mercy there's
just no waiting and again it's
it's hard to do when you've been
when somebody has hurt you
you know
okay would you make a note of that time
that that's great some we make these
little clips it's a very transparent
show i'm like that seems like a great
clip for
to promote the show
i just need to take a swig of my beer
here
yeah mercy yeah i feel like i need to
have like a paper bag to help yeah
liquid death the only uh water that you
have to put in a bag if you want to
drink it on your stoop
i was very moved by that
you know it's interesting it's what i
was trying to do at the fest when i i
wrote out i said find the lowest person
and love them which is a funny thing to
do obviously it's what you're doing but
when you're doing it at a comedy
festival
this is gonna sound like a joke but in
my world it's find the person that
didn't have that great of a set yeah and
talk to them or or the
the stagehand that
is clearly overworked and shuttling
people to the airport or whatever and
then people are
how do you make that person
feel less invisible
it's a great i think it's a simple
answer and i'd love to know yours but
it's like eye contact yeah names
that's right
learn names yeah it's okay so i want to
put this to you it's hard to do i mean
it's again again it's intentional
yeah but it's hard to do but there's a
power in saying somebody's name i i'll
tell you this story and i'd love to hear
your take on it i was on set and i when
i was shooting this last tv show i did i
was
listening to a lot of very out there
stuff a lot of vedanta and a lot of ram
dust and a lot of like it's all an
illusion and it's very groovy but it's a
dream and isn't it far out that we're
having this dream and all this stuff
it's great i like that that's one of the
ways i can go
but i need people like mirabai and i
need people like valerie that will bring
it to the earth and bring it to my body
yeah because i was making the mistake i
was on i've told the story before
forgive me but i was on set and
i didn't know the director's last name
and i actually thought that was kind of
cool because she's the most important
person
on the set i was like you know i don't
even know your last name and she was
like it's on the script like she kind of
seemed offended or not offended but like
she sort of took note of it yeah
and i was like
again i was being very righteous and i
and i pointed out everybody's name that
i knew all these
people on say i was like look chris this
is
like being a piece of [__] now that i
think about it
i didn't do it in a cocky way right
i'm too worried about what people think
to actually be an [__] but yeah i was
kind of like trying to be like i'm not
an [__] look i know all these
people's names
and i come home and i'm like
it doesn't matter like things like names
doesn't matter it's just about
being present and being loved and and
then val said what she often says to me
she's like sure it sounds like you had a
ramdas moment
and i love ramdas and ramdas knew
people's names and stuff but like i had
a very off-the-ground moment and she was
like but richard would have been like
forgive me i forgot your last name
oh of course thomas yes what a beautiful
name is it scandinavian
oh
bless
and when i did it for him he was like
stop it
that breathy voice
and he put his hand up to slap me it was
one of the highlights of my career
but i i
do you relate to what i'm saying the
different altitudes like there is
ultimate truth of like
this is just
god's dream or whatever you want to say
or you could say it's not real or it's
all fleeting or it's a passing show or
anywhere and then there is like hello
father greg yeah isn't it just nice to
say your name
and to look at you like
like you ever
it sounds like you don't struggle with
it based on everything you've done in
your life but well known body is an
excuse to like leave earth no no i i
don't i don't believe in the leaving the
earth part yeah you know but it's it's
all about you know you know tenderness
is kind of the highest form of spiritual
maturity so you want it you know
tenderness is a decision
you know it's not it's not like a thing
that you decide on once and for all but
it's how are you tender with people and
so the homies will say you know we're
used to being watched we're not used to
being seen
and because you know they've been in
prison wow and so if you can create a
place that's safe
then then you people can be seen
and then you can cherish them and that's
kind of the
full monty you know you get to the place
where you're
where you're cherishing people
but you but you have to you know give
some attention to it i mean it's all
it's all about being attentive
and paying attention is the hardest
thing for human beings for me it is
you know because you're getting ahead of
yourself you're lamenting what you did
yesterday
you're anxious about what's going to
happen tomorrow
and yet here you and i are on
talking on this couch and you you don't
want to be any other
any other place
but this moment but that's the hardest
thing for human beings i think
and yet it can feel like a a still lake
you know it feels so nice yeah and yet
we're we're all rivers going around
and it feels really nice to that's why i
was looking forward to this i've been in
a river all week once you're there
you're like why don't i go it's like
when you don't want to meditate or
pray and then once you're in the middle
of it you're not that it's always a good
feeling but sometimes it is right and
you go like why was i afraid of this
right because your brain will never
think it's a good idea
to get rid of itself right
because you got too much
to worry about that's right yeah and i
really think that's a and do
yes
i i think that's the thing with the news
too is is i see the
i'll say perverse pleasure we take in
talking about shootings and stuff i mean
like gory details and we share them with
each other
and i almost see like a superstitious
belief that that of course all of us
have
in worrying about this i'm actually
doing something like my worry and my
is a controversy disgust is a
contribution yeah
it's super it's it i i again i say
you've just caught up to where i was
when i was 13. yeah if i think all the
time about what a piece of [__] i am god
is pleased and now you're like if i
think about these horrors all the time
i'm carrying yeah no that's like might
inside yeah
grief right i'm like i i don't think
that's actually
good right right
have you had any
and feel free to because sometimes
giving language to these things ruins
them but forgive me for asking have you
had any mystical experiences worth
sharing or that you would share
yeah i mean i
i you know in my life i've had these
moments where
where you know you know
and ignatius talks about the gift of
tears and so i've had that many times
when all sudden
i'm just overwhelmed and flooded with
you know
a sense
of i remember in detroit i was making
what we call the long retreat which is
30-day silence
silent retreat
and i just had
these overwhelming moments of
of sobbing you know
and so but it's not mystical in any kind
of
seeing something more about knowing
yes and it's not about kind of being
taken to some other place
it's always pretty rooted in
right here and now
that's similar to to father richard when
he's like talks about being a little boy
looking at his christmas tree and the
whole experiences that he just saw it
that's right it's like we're saying like
if you could see this couch that's right
or when you see people when you know
that you're
you know as kind of
anchored in the present moment with
somebody
[Music]
it's mystical
but i think mystical is is kind of where
we want to be
you know obviously
and it's kind of uh
a way of seeing and and once you see it
you know you do fire all the other gods
once you see it you kind of go you know
i don't want to do that anymore
yeah but it's not kind of
good or bad or moral
it's really about
seeing in the most expansive way is a
joy
a joyous place to be
and then even in terms of kind of being
authentic
you know
staying close to the marrow of the
gospel
as much as you
want to do that is really you know where
joy and fearlessness kind of is sort of
the mark
as opposed to being terrified and sad
joy and fearlessness yeah i think yeah
and then when you feel joyful and and
fearless
then you kind of go
you you know that you're you're kind of
being faithful yeah
as opposed to frightened and and and
just pervasively sad
yeah
you know my death anxiety i don't suffer
from a lot of death anxiety but this
past week at the comedy festival
my dreams and just my
you know those small moments in the
morning
before you put yourself on yeah like i'm
just like oh my god i'm going to die
like
and what's that do for you
i think it's a
a again i'll say perverse sort of
i think i like it i think it's a trip
that i
that i'm like i'm real i'm here i am
worrying but it's kind of helpful i mean
it's kind of like
you know momentum
well yeah i'm gonna be dead longer than
i'm alive
and then you were talking about
humiliation in the canceled person you
know that i kind of find humiliation is
my compass
you know
it it kind of brings you to this
it's a cold
glass of water being thrown into your
face and you kind of go oh okay well
that's not bad that was humiliating yes
but you know that's not bad
well you don't like it i it kind of
because it then you go you know i'm
gonna be dead a lot longer than i am
alive yeah
yeah or dalai lama always says
you know when they ask him about his own
death he says
change of clothing
which i love oh yeah and then once you
kind of go yeah change the clothing
then
changing i mean i'm
because this young woman this morning
was my 256th
young person
killed because of gang violence
and it's not a trick so much as it is
you have to put death in its place
with a quickness otherwise it becomes so
dark you know
otherwise you have to just you have to
kind of say
yeah you know
if death is the worst thing that's ever
going to happen to us you're going to be
toppled by life itself you know so then
you have to i've had to kind of do that
if the worst thing that can happen is
something that's guaranteed to happen
you're gonna have a hard to go exactly
it's very interesting but you know i
don't know who said
none of us will live forever but but all
of us can live in the forever and so
live in the forever live in the forever
and so that there's your choice
i'm going to live in the forever today
you know would you say there's something
eternal in you and i
yeah i would too i was loading you up
yeah no no no certainly certainly
there's a spring it's so funny what do
you mean a spring a spring there's
there's a self-generating source oh yeah
like a source of that that's like water
spring like a water spring yeah yeah
when when you set a well
or a fire or whatever you want to think
of it as
so in in my
uh experience that experience i was
alluding to earlier it was a psychedelic
experience but i i think it was very
sacred and i felt like when we die we go
in we don't go out if that made that was
the big takeaway yeah as i was like
where you go
when you die is actually where you
already are and have always been and
it's actually the only place
to go
so it actually took this
this fear of crossing a chasm where the
river sticks or like you're going
somewhere you're going off into the
cosmos it's like you're actually going
the only place that there is you're
going home this is a nice way to put it
i like home i like home too yeah but it
it really was experience it was like a
swooshing
below me and there was like a upness to
it but i was like
oh i was there the whole time which is a
very common right mystical
knowing i was there the whole time yeah
that's exactly where
it's kind of where you began it's where
you begin but then you and
talk about
if you'd like
spirituality being about like unlearning
you know like meaning
we come as children and i think again
richard talks about one of the reasons
we're so fascinated with babies is
because they're still connected often i
know they cry and i had a baby recently
but like
they can be so close to that home that
we just want to
hold them i know they're adorable but
hold them and kiss them i want to
be where they are sort of thing but then
there's the sameness of it all of us are
born
wanting the same things
you know and
and you know
[Music]
we
we're human beings and so we all share
the same last name you know beings
and so how do we
because that that happens a lot you know
where people feel
like choices people will say uh how do
we help these kids make better choices
and i go wow not all choices are created
equal and it's really not about choices
choices is
you know uh
it's a kind of a projection that people
say
you know where they'll especially about
the population that i
work with and walk with
is you know how do you get them to know
the difference between right and wrong
well it has nothing to do with right and
wrong they they were born into the world
wanting the same thing you wanted
and terrible things happened to them i
don't know how else to say it
you know and
and so it's not about
choices it's about i don't know chances
and it's about somehow
finding our commonality as human beings
that
that you know
and we have to let go of it it's it's uh
unlearning things but it's jettisoning
things you know
you just toss these things off the boat
you know yeah and i'm 68 years old and
i'm
i'm still doing it
you know you know where you go yeah you
know i don't
good and bad you know there is no such
thing as good people and bad people and
and once you let go of that you kind of
go
you know god doesn't see good people or
bad people god sees god's people
you know and there's a kind of a
sameness
you know and it's not about measuring
god i think is always saying what's all
the measuring about
what is that god is terrible at math or
god can't add and subtract yeah yeah
yeah which is just a funny way of saying
right it's already done yeah it's
already yeah i i don't want to get
derailed us into a a discussion of free
will
but sometimes i take comfort in the fact
and human beings don't tend to like this
i'm like i don't know man i think i'm a
part of a thing
a whole thing
and even me saying this right now you
could trip out and get paranoid but i'm
just kind of like i'm a result
of all of it
you know does that make sense yeah
meaning it's not so much that i don't
have free will it's more that i am
responding to the whole i'm not subject
to object this whole i love the word
undulating but the whole thing is
undulating in the same way that a wave
kind of thinks it's a wave but i'm
really a relationship if that makes
sense and it's less about whether or not
i do the right thing or the wrong thing
or as perfect or as not perfect or
whatever that means
but i'm uh
i'm a part of the of the whole if that
makes sense yeah
and
yeah i think so and i think how do we uh
you know have have greater
you know a greater larger wider
kind of way to receive people
you know rather than
you know our presumption that god is
wanting us to
to kind of be better at it
you know when it's i mean i don't know
why this you know like when you talked
earlier about lapping god
but it's
what you will do with leela and what any
parent does with a kid
is
you know unconditional love doesn't even
get close to it yeah
there's a no matter whatness to your
love yeah that
that you know it's like
you don't want anything from your kid
you only want for your kids yeah
and
and how much more so god
yes you know and that's i don't know why
that's so hard for people
you know to understand i think the
parent i think it's one of the reasons
why jesus was always using
abba and father imagery
and when i actually have a joke we call
them bits i have a bit about it um
it hasn't really been working i think
it's hilarious but i go i made my
daughter dinner and i gave it to her she
was watching tv and i put it down and
she just started eating it she didn't
say thank you and it occurred to me i i
didn't care
i don't have to tell you that i didn't
care what occurred to me maybe i should
say say thank you and then i was like
you know what man i yanked her into
existence like it's my
doing obviously that's not exactly right
but i was like i brought her here
like
the joking way would be like it's my
fault that she's here
yeah so she doesn't know me [__] right
like and then i kind of turn on my
parents it's like your father worked
hard to send you to college it's like
yeah that's what he should do it's very
similar to sidney poitier his speech
about uh
your parents don't you don't know your
parents anything
and but there's but what i'm
experiencing as a parent
is like a genuine like you don't owe me
[__]
full stop like you don't have to do you
don't have to say thank you daddy for
dinner i'm like
i got to cook you dinner this is
incredible but why why it can be so hard
to make the jump that god feels that way
about us right that we're in debt
richard has another beautiful sorry to
keep quoting richard but whenever we
talk about these things he's in my mind
and he says like all of our little
efforts
to please god
uh i hope i'm getting this right but he
says they're sort of adorable they're
like when our kid makes a drawing and
it's it's supposed to be a cat and it's
really bad but we love it and we put it
on the fridge he's like that's like us
right it's not that we did it perfectly
it's not it's just that you are yeah
it's done it's like it's like what
you're saying about mercy it's done
right and it's like what i experienced
in my experience i was like it's all
done yeah we're both already
whereas we're alive and we're dead it's
all at the same time almost it doesn't
even make any sense and it's knowing
that you're at home yeah yeah you've
been there all along you were there the
whole time that's right and you were
there and you were there it's like
dorothy at the end of the wizard of oz
yeah yeah truly truly great
i'm feeling deeply satisfied by this
conversation i hope you don't go
likewise okay good we've been doing this
for like nine hours oh my god yeah it's
been a while has anyone ever told you
you sound like jim gaffigan i was
listening to you on a podcast and i was
like this sounds like jim gaffney
isn't he great yeah a catholic
yeah um well i have other things to ask
but i really feel
i feel great i feel like we did it so
badly you've been
oh it's sitting here for a typical
episode is two hours is it really yeah
two sometimes
i think our record is almost four hours
and then you cut stuff out no
no that's my own little mesh message
that everything belongs yeah it all
stays in it all sticks in
let me
here's a question i really did want to
ask and i know you were at a funeral
this morning and then we'll have a
couple quick questions and we'll get out
of here no problem but
what do you say
at a funeral
that's not aimed towards improving the
community because i on your 60 minute
piece there actually was you speaking at
a funeral
um
and talking using is a as a great
opportunity to talk about how are we
going to stop this and that's in those
days i i did that a lot okay yeah i just
like sometimes i for all of my spiritual
study and stuff if a tragedy happens a
young man
a young woman is beaten to death or shot
or whatever it may be
i'm i'm sometimes talk about
humbling i'm humbled by the fact that
i'm like
i really
all i do is listen to richard and merton
and all of this stuff
and yet if a crazy tragedy happens
sometimes i'm left to be like
i really don't know what to say
uh you're uniquely uniquely qualified
what a sad thing and also what a
beautiful thing you've had so many of
them
what do you
offer to grieving people they're
grieving people listening
they're grieving people
they'll always be grieving people
what is something that you offer
uh in terms of comfort or perspective or
well you know
i can't we can't help but quote richard
but part of it is like holding the grief
holding the pain until it transforms you
and so that's kind of the even if you
don't say that that's kind of where you
want people to be
you know you but you also want people to
connect to
memories you know
like
the finger pointing to the moon
is not the moon it just points to the
moon and so in what ways did this person
touch you in such a way
that you it pointed to the moon it it
it revealed the kind of god that we
actually have
not the god we've settled for but the
god we actually have and then you can
kind of reconnect
especially if you have stories about
people
you know
even though it's so tragic
but in the old days i remember it was
always cautionary tale it was uh
you know
lefty who died would want you to
put your guns away that kind of thing i
remember i did that a lot yeah
i did that a lot but i don't do that so
much anymore because
you know if people want to make sense of
death
you know and and how do you
how do you really communicate that death
has no power how do you not allow it to
take hold of you
you know and you also kind of
dispel nonsense about why did god do
this you know
and how do you do that well i mean
god didn't have anything to do with it
you know
and i'm a big believer and god protects
me from nothing and sustains me
in everything
a homie the other day
you couldn't unpack that enough for me
honestly yeah go ahead but i mean like
in terms of prayer because i don't
really
i don't believe that prayer works
but i believe that praying does
i love that yeah only in as much as it's
it's sustaining me like it's funny when
i was in um
[Music]
in
albuquerque santa fe
actually had dinner with um mirabai and
this homie fabian
and a woman named laura who works at
homeboy
and he's an artist and
uh i don't know we were talking about
prayer before we actually had dinner
with her and i said well fabian what do
you do and he goes i just sit there
silent
and i say hold me
wow and i loved it and he's a gang
member former
addict
um hold on hold me what a good mantra
yeah and i use it as a mantra and ever
since then i kind of just
hold me that's like abba that's like
daddy yeah because it's it's not about
you know help me pass the algebra test
you know it's
it's not a thing i can do and there's
nothing you can do
but you can hold me
and so then it's a sustenance you know
yeah and you kind of do that at funerals
you kind of say let's hold each other
let's walk each other home let's live in
the forever because
we're all gonna die
yeah but let's live in the forever don't
look away from it let's look at it right
right and you know
it's funny that i asked you for hope or
or or cause that's what we want from
funerals i want you to tell me that well
and also grief you said grief yeah you
know and how do you make sense of it and
how do you hold it
long enough
so that it transforms you
yes to use it
but death not being the worst thing that
can happen yeah
nobody and the worst thing that can
happen is not
knowing the god of love
and and finding your true self and
loving so i i think i always try to do
that
in homily about a homie who's gone too
early
you
before he left us
he came to know that his true self in
loving
and then you can always find examples
of when he did that
and he was that
and he inhabited that with some fullness
so you can always tell those stories
because they're all there they're always
there yeah and then you go oh
then the fate worse than death
is not knowing that and he knew it he
felt it he had it he showed it to you
right and then all of a sudden you're
you're you're connecting to a larger
love
that's
that that that says to death death as a
homie said to me once who's dead
but he said death is a punk death is a
punk
and homies understand that because they
go
punk is sort of
is uh
like more bark than bite yeah he's a
punk he talks that way but he's a punk
wow and homies know exactly what that
means and if you say death is a punk
oh okay and it's in its place suddenly
you've put it in its place right right
which is like scripture you know you say
you death wears your sting sting and
yeah or or they said of jesus uh
death
couldn't hold him
right
and ramdas has that thing where he talks
in you know it was the 60s or early 70s
and he's like oh you're hung up on death
here i'll show you
like you can kill me
yeah
he humbled himself to death right and
death on a cross
you know it's like that idea that he's
like to me he
i grew up believing that jesus was
something to be worshipped again and to
be i'm not saying i don't love christ
i'm just saying now i see it as much
more urgent and it's like you do this
too
like you you do this as well yeah like
i'm modeling
a human life
uh
and that's what you're saying yeah
there's like some degree of
transformation some degree of realizing
that death is a punk yeah some degree of
not buying into the myth
that
you know
we're all supposed to be billionaires on
rocking chairs smoking cigars i mean you
know is that it yeah
heated toilet seats yeah
it's interesting yeah
but how are we surprised by death it's
still it's kind of astounding to me it's
the most inevitable thing it's the only
thing it's that you only have that will
happen to absolutely everybody and yet
we're utterly
i'm gonna do it bob smacked when yeah oh
my god he died
well yeah i'm gonna run a joke but
another bit by you yeah please i yell at
the crowd i go you're afraid to die
you're afraid to die
i go surely temple died
you're more of a candy ass than shirley
temple you laugh i'd like to take you on
the road and watch how that joke does
not work
i go my nana died she didn't even speak
english which i think is so funny but to
me
that's me calling it out going like
everyone does it
you should actually take comfort
in the fact that everyone does it
cavemen
died alone in a desert just like
dehydrated you can't do that
it's every single thing that's ever been
like you has done it yeah there's so
there's like a comfort in the lineage in
the rite of passage right
in the sameness of it
chinese spirituality death and love are
the great gifts that most people leave
unopened yeah and ramnes is all about
that and i believe that the people that
were present at his passing i think
he you know i don't mean to idolize him
i'm just saying i think he did it i
think he was not afraid
to die in fact that was one of my
favorite ramadan stories i was with him
in maui and
dasima who was taking care of him was
like he almost died a week ago we were
so scared and here's frail little ramdas
looks like a skeleton in a hawaiian
shirt basically and he tugs on her and
he goes not me
not me and he knew i needed to hear that
you know what i mean he knew we all
needed to use it yeah yeah but i
believed him yeah that's
you know
that's good stuff
yeah because he didn't buy it yeah he
didn't buy it
taking off a tight shoe that's what he
always do yeah
but that's also wholeness and holiness
but yeah we
we reject
a huge part of the whole
system
this obsession with longevity
let's upload our consciousnesses to
computers
death will be obsolete ray kurzweil
you know make it to 2054 and you'll
never die basically
i don't know if you've heard anything no
i haven't no he's the guy that think
that believes if we make it to 2054 the
singularity will happen
which i believe is ai i don't i'm not an
expert it's like ai and the merging of
technology and biology
nanobots cleaning your arteries oh i'm
not interested but yeah
yeah i wanted to uh somebody called me
twice
sorry nobody my phone's always on do not
disturb but they call twice they know
it'll ring so i thought maybe it was
forgiving something sure and here we are
having a i'm really enjoying this
conversation likewise um
clockwise the homies always say that
clockwise yeah
clockwise and you sort of likewise
conservate
that was one that you put in an email to
me we'll sit down and conservatively oh
no
conversate conversite yeah they always
say and we were there we were converse
you know we were conversating i love it
yeah authenticious yeah no
that's not it
authenticious that's a real word see
real words it's fictitious no no it's
not the authenticity is not a real word
yeah all right that's the right one man
have you these are the questions i ask
everybody it's more interesting to ask
you
have you ever almost died
well i've had leukemia oh did you went
through chemo and okay
and i wouldn't trade that time
from for anything tell me what you mean
well just because uh you know i would
get homies would leave me voicemail
messages no it's our turn to take care
of you very
very sweet a big huge homie named grumpy
came in and said uh
what big tears in his eyes he says what
do i have that you need meaning organs
you know
it was just it was just non-stop
uh i remember homie came in a little guy
and i was going through chemo at that
point i'd come to the office and he got
the news kind of late and he was just
they were so stricken by it you know and
uh
he says i hear you have leukemia i said
yeah i do
and there's a kind of an awkward silence
and he says
my cat had leukemia
and i said
yeah she died and i said oh god
awfully glad you stopped by
that's right really ready to go lift me
up it's a good bit it's a solid bit but
uh
so and then the homies would drive me
to uh chemo and pick me up which was
clearly more harrowing than actual
receiving chemotherapy was having the
homies drive me oh really oh my god
horrible drivers
and of course i'm a horrible passenger i
am too yeah horrible because if i'm not
driving it it can't happen so yeah
um i knew because i told christy i said
i'll send a car
oh move that you were doing it ninji was
like he likes driving himself and i was
like i decline every car i'm offering as
well i've never yeah except sometimes
they insist
yeah that's happened to you too
they want to make sure you get that yeah
which just seems crazy but oh well but
you can control what you listen to you
can draw it like that yeah drive i i
even thought about you i was like
i don't know why something you said made
me think of the opportunity driving
is
oh to be
we say on the show you say something
similar to be the universe winking we
keep waiting for the universe to wink at
us but you forget what an opportunity
you have to be the universe winking yeah
and anybody that that some
you know you would call them an idiot
that just made the absolute goofiest
left blocking and you can stop you can
be the one that stops and goes you know
i think i've done something like that
myself yeah there's something really
beautiful yeah yeah in that so what's
the state of your leukemia now i'm in um
say i hear your cancer's in intermission
you know
now we say yeah apparently it's stepped
out to the lobby to buy popcorn yeah
may the line be long you know but isn't
it i mean this is another round but it's
also kind of one of those things where
you you know
every year i've almost had to have
something radiation or whatever but all
during the pandemic
it was for the first time ever i didn't
need to get anything wow yeah but i saw
him okay
but you must run into what i started to
say was ramdas
believes that the church the modern
church now the doctors are the priests
like we worship life
and and will lie and
the doctor will come in and tell the
patient how good they're doing and go in
the hall and be like they won't last the
night
like there's no honesty and he made a
not a living he wasn't being paid but he
would he would be the one that would go
in and say i understand you're dying or
you know like that would want to name it
yeah talk about the thorn again to get
under it and just be like
no i'm not gonna
deny this like how many of us die
in a moment of denial yeah it's like
that's i'm not opening the present so
this is a blunt question but
how do you feel about
your death now like i was having all
that death anxiety how are you doing
with the thought of it
the inevitable thing you know
i um i really have to pee oh yeah no
it's not my death it's
[Laughter]
let's take a pee break and we'll we'll
do that yes of course
could you still do it
not really wow because you're good oh
thank you
yeah i am i mean it was funny and clever
but it's also just and i look like oh my
god
oh yeah
yeah oh that's so sweet
see that's how you know i'm a three is
that i figured out the exact number i
could do that would be impressive and
then i stopped
you know what i mean i was like there's
no difference in impressiveness between
four
maybe like 44 but like four and
seven it's all about the same so i got
him
and i it was too much effort
but i'm glad you like that these are
these are mine too that cat and that you
know it's great and batman hugging the
joker i like that one
that's that's mercy
you should keep doing it oh thank you
yeah
we're just coming back we both had a
bathroom break and there's a god that
was intense
urgent you mean yeah yeah me too
honestly thank you we've we've uh this
has been great this has been so
enjoyable yeah for me too and and and
were
we were just dead
right there as we just had such a one of
the great joys of life
[Laughter]
tell me yeah i'm not afraid of death and
i and i i ask myself sometimes
is that true
yeah he's in frame yeah and i just uh
wait am i okay oh yeah you're good just
because you moved i was checking okay um
is it true that you're not afraid to
death yeah or are you in denial no i
think i i i'm truly not oh i wasn't
asking you but that's what you ask
yourself yeah that's right yeah and i uh
but you do ask yourself you kind of say
is that really true
and i think it is i just i've
i've been around death a lot
a lot a lot a lot
so i've had to put it in its place and
so i have had to do that for myself
personally as well you know
and then having cancer and you know
and then at least initially thinking
yeah this probably will end in death
sooner than
not
and it didn't
you know
and then you're also aware you were
talking about earlier about how doctors
you know they make so many the advances
are kind of extraordinary and every
month there's a new thing you know a new
treatment let's try this
you know
so uh yeah i don't think i am i'll ask
you what i asked richard
uh he had a beautiful answer
and
you you'll
know what it is but i was like
what do you think the chances are
because i was thinking about death and i
was like when we die
and again even having been in that
oneness and all that
wonderfulness i'm like what do you think
the chances are that it's something odd
or confusing or strange or overwhelming
like you know the buddhists
train
for the bardos
right for the idea that they're gonna
travel through something and they're
gonna have to keep their center while a
giant ear
full flies through the sky or whatever
right right or like a fire made out of
cotton candy yeah and there's their
mother in it or something and they just
kind of have to float around and not be
attached and then they get to go into
the void or whatever
and if i'm being honest that reminds me
those types of thoughts remind me of my
fundamental sphere of hell that it's
that god is
somehow not
to be trusted that he's going to want to
send me into a fun house
filled with mirrors and
you know
skittles coming out of my nose or
whatever it is
um
and richard was was just like the saints
always
trust that that they're
that
that god is trustworthy god is worthy of
their trust
and i'm wondering if do you have
do you have any remnants of that feeling
like what if it's something weird or
what if it's something frightening or
strange or yeah
you know
i guess it's based on my psychedelic
thing like i i'm i'm less interested in
psychedelics than i used to be
uh and one of the reasons is i mean my
life has changed but i'm also like i
don't want to
smoke something and
be
a frog
for its entire lifespan
then come back and be like i was a
[__] frog like that doesn't sound fun
for me right but then i'm like
the after or the afterlife or what
happens at the moment of death could be
just as strange or can i
rest in that just hold me place
does that make sense yeah yeah
absolutely makes sense but i don't also
i don't think about it too much you know
because i
i'm not afraid of it
it feels like rest i trust god
i i don't i don't uh i don't really i
don't believe in hell
you know or like the mystics would say
okay there's a hell but it's i think
it's empty
you know i forgot that one i love that
one and and so i believe that kind of
thing so i don't really
you know what are the chances
that this trustworthy god
is gonna pull a fast one you know
right zero
you know there's zero chance of that
so so then you know everything becomes
more spacious and more wide
and more inclusive
and which is so frustrating you know
kind of in a church
that
isn't inclusive
and doesn't really reflect
the spacious god we actually have
so that's hard always
you know
but you know
i think it's
it's trustworthy
that's
you know
the god that we actually have
and ramnes talks about that we either
have our personal experience this isn't
be here now or we can trust
uh those that came before us
you know your christ and your buddhas
like there's
i would like to have the conversion
experience myself or
when in doubt you can trust those right
that happens right that's right brought
the message back that's right yeah if we
weren't lucky enough to get knocked off
our donkey that's right
i know there's no reference to the
donkey
well thank you so much the the final
final question for today
is um can you and i bet you have
a good answer can you think of a time
you laughed from your belly that that's
how i'll ask you but at a time you
laughed really hard yeah from your
stomach
just if there's a memory where you're
crying with laughter
what were you doing how old were you
what happened i don't know i have so
many of them and i've written so many of
them and
isn't that funny that when you when
you're asked to recall one i i can't i
actually would do very badly with this
yeah yeah how about but for me it's it's
a constant thing at home boy in
where we're peop because being able to
laugh from the stomach is also there's a
freedom where you don't have to worry
about what people will think or speaking
of new yorker cartoons yeah there was
like it's a cartoon where it's two
aristocrats on a picnic blanket like in
the 1700s
and they're going like i'm all for joy
and ecstasy but those ridiculous faces
or something like something about how
gosh it is to make the faces and the
sounds and i was like yeah the victorian
period was really
against laughing so hard you fart that's
right exactly but i mean like isn't that
what we also really want that's the
laughs
yeah yeah
and my answer is always the time i made
val laughs so hard she farted and it it
made us
die
even more yes to be that safe
and isn't that
holding and it belonging and being safe
but you know you take it for granted you
think it's just about
funny people making other people laugh
yeah but it's really about
safety
where people feel safe
and and uh in the comfort it's about
home if we're all walking each other
home then there's no greater
reminder of home than laughing from the
stomach you know
and and that's you want to kind of
create a place that's safe enough where
people can
experience that you know
yeah because who was val when she was
laughing so hard she lost control of her
body yeah she wasn't really there i mean
she was or she was the most there than
she yeah she was out of body experience
i love that well
so much love to you people can donate to
homeboy industries at 25 million a year
endeavor if the number hasn't changed
it's 40 million 40 million okay
inflation times are changing
and i love that you said that even
though obama gave you that award that
the government's donation has been
negligible or something that hasn't been
too much it's not too much so i'm only
mentioning that to say
um
let's donate let's and let's do
recurring donations to homeboy
industries yes
and check out your wonderful books and i
i i'm just so grateful for this time
yeah me too thanks of course it's so
silly but we have the guest say the
catchphrase which is keep it crispy keep
it crispy
without hesitation
i guess another way to say it is don't
be a punk
and say keep it crispy he said it twice
keep it crispy
you gotta keep it seriously the best why
do you not include it in your act who
knows who richard is i mean i do
i it's a lot of my best i know what i
should go wow if i had my eyes closed
hello
[Laughter]
father g
um well thank you so much let's go
[Music]